foreign
we have to I don't want to talk about
this but we have to
because our life is a hellscape trump
big papa Trump remember him oh whoa whoa
yeah he promised yesterday uh-huh here
we go huge announcement you you just
announcement coming yeah and I mean with
the Twitter stuff going on and everybody
like this is you know it's a big [ __ ]
moment to really really execute the
perfect political move uh at a time when
his numbers are fading so I missed it
obviously we were tired from the trip
what was the big announcement
well I have a video you want to watch it
sure cool
hello everyone this is Donald Trump
hopefully your favorite President of all
time better
I mean dude George Washington was pretty
badass
honestly Jonathan was President hey you
know what John Adams was pretty good too
if we're being honest although pretty
much the first like eight of them were
pretty solid yeah um
Trump George Washington
had a opportunity and very much so a lot
of people were willing to say we'll make
you the king yeah exactly
and he went
that's what got us in this yes for a
couple years and then I'm gonna go back
to my [ __ ] slave plantation and I'm
gonna drink mint juleps it's so funny
though it's like we're gonna make you a
king ghost that's what kind of got us in
this in the first place so I'll just be
proud I'm a president how about that all
right how about you know hey eight years
we hang out you threw a tantrum yeah
you you basically threw a tantrum
because you lost a rigged election
because of all of the people you did
nothing about for four years conspiring
against you correct
it's a little different it's so so again
and again I say this for the show but
they're called Danny polishuk releasing
an nft Now read the room well yeah he
didn't even well he didn't announce that
yet oh sorry I apologize we were
building to that I know yo at least
that's the only thing he's built he
didn't have to build a [ __ ] wall
thanks man it's better than Washington
Gina was hey by the way by the way by
the way Gina was right about you Virgie
you are a cool cat
the bee's knees Virgie you're a cool cat
with an important announcement to make
bro this is not a joke
first you made such a good joke at what
point that a drunk Geno Pat his head
like he was a dog
and I was [ __ ] howling yeah the old
Italian thing yeah he gave him the old
his [ __ ] guy exactly yeah exactly
this guy over here I'm like oh [ __ ]
guy
I honestly thought by the end of it he
was going to offer Virgie a job
I'm doing my first hey you want to
protect me against Like Pat Dixon
punching me Virgie I'm gonna put you in
a Gina I'm gonna put you in a Gino suit
and what you're doing is you're gonna
sit at my chair itself
sorry this is a big announcement better
than Washington with an important
announcement to make I'm doing my first
official Donald J Trump nft collection
right here and right now they're called
Trump digital trading card
um
what
nft stands for non-fungal token which
means it can't be I I know I know you
can't find the token
huh wow wow I guess Merce is just one of
those libtard retards huh because if you
don't by the way even hardcore Maga
people today on Twitter to even to their
and I don't like giving them credit but
even to their credit even hardcore Maga
people are like hey man what the [ __ ]
are you doing
Parts these cards feature some of the
really incredible artwork pertaining to
unless it's [ __ ] uh unless it's uh
unless it's unless it's major Tom's plan
no we're not
my life and my career it's been very
exciting you can collect your Trump
digital cards just like a baseball card
all right merch here's the thing I don't
want you to double up emergency
I don't want to double I don't want to
double up unfungible tokens first I
don't fudge it I don't want I don't want
to double it up merch I'll be honest
with you I got you the cowboy
um wait there are different ones oh I
love I love that merch hadn't seen merch
we went to the website
do you want to see here let's check them
out uh I'll read them for you uh all
right all right you know what this will
be actually easier
let me minimize minimize and then do
this okay here you go
uh all right so Miami dinner with Trump
this is the cowboy one you ready
spend a memorable evening in Miami for
an exclusive dinner hosted by Trump
wait do you go to the dinner right yeah
you can win these things oh you can win
so he's doing loot crates so this is
worse so this is work that's not true
that's not true he's doing loot this is
not easy rice gum no this is not no no
no this is not no no my new vice
presidential candidate ice Poseidon
[ __ ]
hey remember what I spec help me with
the young vote remember when I ripped
all his viewers off without that [ __ ]
coin and he never apologized to giving
the money back uh that was Donald Trump
actually
um
huh yeah no that was Donald Trump
oh
uh Maro Largo okay so the if you if you
get the astronaut Trump
Mar-A-Lago group cocktail hour
experience a meet and greet with Trump
in this luxurious private Palm Beach
Resort okay so another dinner it's the
same thing right but this time it's a
little different it's a little different
oh cause you just meet and greet you
don't even get to eat anything correct
like [ __ ] you you're not even any uh
hors d'oeuvres or nothing all right so
then there's then there's a one-on-one
meeting with number 45 and that's Trump
standing in front a bunch of gold bars
all right what if I win it
and I give it to Nick Fuentes
but then you're a man of your word I am
allowed to transfer an nft to the next
person I won the one-on-one meeting with
you I'm giving it to Nick Fuentes
because now I want to watch everything
burn or no you know what better yet I
want to give it to Milo so he can gloat
at you for 15 minutes
uh then I have absolutely destroyed you
how does it feel no you will sit okay I
bought this nft with stolen money okay
play golf with Trump and your friends
join Donald on the green for an
exclusive one hour of golf with your two
closest friends
oh they get better
um then there's the individual Zoom call
with Donald Trump speak directly with
Donald on a private Zoom call to ask the
questions you've always wanted to ask
I wish I could win that one because I've
got some questions
uh group Zoom session with 45 meet Trump
via Zoom alongside fellow digital
trading cards hand signed memorabilia
receive a limited edition signed
photograph of Donald J Trump as a prize
good collectible win one of the 25
incredibly rare gold digital trading
cards digitally signed by Donald Trump
[ __ ] you so it's a Loot Crate I hate you
that's not true because the Loot Crate
is at least in a game where I might get
something that I like there's nothing I
want here you know what I mean I want
the Charizard Trump I heard that's the
most valuable one it's only if it's a
shiny one only if it's a shiny one
is he
um [ __ ] yeah but this is he not
aware of Alzheimer's yep
the nfts are like crypto is dying right
now the stock like well no forget about
the crypto percent the stock market is
dying right now can I go one better
dying we're all gonna die we're all
dying right now we're all dying
everything and then on top of that
crypto which is a very speculative asset
is super dying
where do they think nfts like in the
equation right now who's paying money
for nfts still
this Boomers
I mean the only people that I could
think would buy this I mean May correct
me if I'm wrong Marsh would be Boomers
right
yeah it has to be is that but it's but
why would no not Boomers is what Boomer
even knows what an nft is
I don't no no you're misunderstanding me
Tim Davis that's why they're like
digital trading yes they don't they
don't know what they are they'll buy
them anyway they're making it they're
dumbing it down
uh let's hear a little more hard or
other Collectibles here's one of the
best parts each card comes with an
automatic chance to win amazing prizes
like dinner with me I don't know if
that's an amazing prize
no it is not it was at one point not now
I don't want to well done steak a Diet
Coke with a loser I'll do that if you
were a winner I'd be amazing
uh say I only eat dinner with people
that do these selections
you know what's weird like
to think like just a few years ago if
like somebody had said hey you want to
come to this thing that Trump's going to
be at it's a dinner you guys can come
we'll get you the passes and everything
you might even get to meet him we would
have been like [ __ ] yeah that's pretty
[ __ ] cool and it's gone from that to
like
yeah I don't know man probably not like
well yeah what's the dinner looking like
wait how fancy is the dinner is it
McDonald's yeah because if I show up and
it's like Pizza Hut yeah I'm gonna be
man I'm gonna be pretty pissed but uh if
it's a fancy thing and other fancy
people will be there but we just
wouldn't care about Trump you're like I
don't know I'll go there might be other
cool people there but
but it's what we have we're golf with
you and a group of your friends at one
of my beautiful golf courses and they
are beautiful
I'm also doing Zoom calls a one-on-one
meeting autographing memorabilia and so
much more that's oh we're doing a lot
my official Trump digital trading cards
are 99 which doesn't sell which of these
cards helps me defeat the blue eyes
white dragon oh you're thinking of
Yu-Gi-Oh wow you're thinking of Yu-Gi-Oh
um what about magic the Gathering could
I do it I would honestly Trump I'm not
gonna lie that'd be the [ __ ] own
couple of Magic the Gathering cards I
see I see a lot of [ __ ] losers
playing that [ __ ] all the time and they
always pay high dollar for them shits
let me tell you something you better
stop because you know what's gonna
happen you're gonna kick me out of your
little group and then I'm gonna care
about all the sick stuff they were doing
there
in your little magic group
very much for what you're getting oh
awesome Jeremy all of a sudden I care
now relax Jeremy buy one and you will
join me all right if we let you back in
will you not tell anyone about all the
pedophilia
um do I get my deck back yes okay yeah
sure that's fine
exclusive Community it's my community
and I think it's something you're going
to like and you're going to like it a
lot they also make perfect gifts so you
can buy them with your credit card or
crypto there
voices I just saw in Royce's face now I
do
haven't heard that haven't heard that
name in a long time
who you need is an email address go to
college oh it's going to be a lot of
lots of money folks I have a feeling a
lot of money to fight the globalists I
I'm pretty sure a lot of people the only
people that buy this have at AOL and at
Hotmail as their email addresses
some cars this kind of feels like what
Conor McGregor's comeback is going to
feel like like somebody on steroids well
yeah but like somebody that we all know
is just it's the best years are in the
rear view now and it's not going to be
like you already kind of you know blew
it when you broke that leg and you know
what I mean and now it's like you'll get
a rehab to take a long time to come back
doesn't be an older guy now he probably
could like it's like Trump could
probably still scrap but but it's gonna
be a go it's gonna be a shell five years
ago I want to see I want to see the
people that we're seeing like y'all
Trump is still better than to Santa tell
me now is he now go ahead tell me watch
this and throw me on tell me
Ron DeSantis won't do this because he's
not
as much of a [ __ ] Lord
I'm Ron DeSantis right I would just like
find the most legal way possible we're
not even I would get Ron DeSantis just
regular playing cards
right right yeah and I would have them
made like with whatever I haven't made
my own personal money and then have 100
of the money for the sale of the cards
go to like Hurricane Relief and make
them like you know five bucks a pack hey
you know let me just sell them on a
website dude and I guarantee you he you
would get so many out of state
non-florida purchases of those cars and
five bucks a pack and he just raises a
bunch of money for Hurricane things just
having a real and it's like hey at least
my cards you know it's a deck of cards
so you could you could use them on a
plane
you know he could do something with him